out on the heels of an official
confirmation for a sequel to the batman
after this year's cinemacon it's safe to
say that matt reese's interpretation of
the character is a critical and audience
darling but one of the most heavily
criticized aspects of the film was the
third act matt reeves did share some
insight on his creative intent behind
the final act in the apple exclusive
director's commentary firstly matt
reeves did not want to introduce any new
gadgets that batman could utilize in his
fight with riddler's followers he's
pretty much equipped with everything he
had from the beginning of the film
furthermore he wanted this entire
sequence to represent batman serving a
penance and punishment for not being
smart enough for putting all the
riddler's clues together
lastly batman's descent into the water
below symbolizes his baptism as it's the
first time he's made a sacrificial move
as batman for gotham thus he re-emerges
a completely different character from
the one we meet at the onset
you